we have breaking news is lunchtime
Russian officials have said that Ukraine
tried to attack the Kremlin with drones
alleging that it is a terrorist act and
underlines their right to respond well
we're joined Now by former air Vice
Marshall Sean Bell and Sean we're
getting reports now a video on on
Russian social media apparently showing
a plume of smoke over the Kremlin what
do we know about what's happened
well as ever Jane we're in an
information War at the moment so details
are very
um sparse what we apparently two drones
were attacking the Kremlin last night
but it's very difficult to tell exactly
what has happened after all there's an
information war going on
um Ukraine has made clear that they've
been doing attacks in an asymmetric
approach but tend to be targets just
over the border into Russia nothing
quite as outrageous as this but it is
worth pointing out that Moscow has been
preparing lines to take in the events
that Ukraine does gain some ground on
its forthcoming spring offensive and
there are a lot of commentators that
believe that Moscow will launch a few
sort of false flag
incidents inside Russia to focus Russia
uh domestic audience on the fact that
Russia needs to protect his own people
and therefore almost justifying whilst
it isn't so successful in Ukraine
because actually it's protecting its own
forces but the truth is at the moment
Ukraine is doing lots of activity with
drones we've seen the fire just the
other day at sevastopol there's another
fire overnight just to the east of the
Kirks Bridge which looks like it was a
drone attack and likewise there was a um
a rail train in Russia was derailed just
near Belgrade apparently very recently
so there's lots of asymmetric attacks
but it does feel odd that Ukraine will
be as so audacious as to mount something
in Moscow I'm sure more details will
come out we'll get it to you as just as
soon as we've got it okay thanks very
much all